I think my cousin was getting married. This is almost 10 years ago now. Ray Tittara had to go to a wedding. It was time to dress up. And Ray needed to look good, because their date was incredibly stylish. At the time, I was newly dating my partner, who really experienced joy in getting dressed up for things
我想我表弟当时要结婚了。这大概是近 10 年前的事了。雷·蒂塔拉 (Ray Tittara) 得去参加一场婚礼。是时候盛装打扮了。雷需要看起来很帅，因为他们的女伴衣着极为时髦。当时，我刚开始和我的伴侣交往，我的伴侣在为各种活动精心打扮时会感到由衷的快乐，
in a way that I did not relate to and really wanted to experience. Like, if my partner is putting on a velvet floor-length dress, I'm like, oh, dammit, that's good. Ray normally wears kind of androgynous casual clothes. You know, like jeans, Hawaiian shirts, gray sweaters, but by and large, formal wear is still so starkly gendered. For this wedding, Ray realized they were gonna have to get a suit. I just knew that I probably needed a suit because I didn't feel comfortable
而这种快乐我当时并不懂，并且真的很想体验一下。比如，如果我的伴侣穿上一件丝绒及地长裙，我就会想，哦，天哪，这太棒了。雷平时通常穿中性风的休闲服装。你知道的，比如牛仔裤、夏威夷衬衫、灰色毛衣，但总的来说，正装的性别界限依然非常分明。为了这场婚礼，雷意识到他们得买一套西装。我当时就觉得自己可能需要一套西装，因为我觉得
wearing anything else for, you know, when I had to get dressed up. Ray was not excited about wearing a suit. It honestly seemed kind of boring and intimidating when you contrast it with the thrill and excitement of floor-length velvet dresses or jump suits and makeup and heels. Ray watched their partner in awe. I was just like, wow, whatever that is, I was like, whatever that is, I need that. It just seemed like it was gonna be really hard to get that special dress-up feeling from a suit.
穿别的很不自在，你知道的，当我不得不盛装打扮的时候。雷对穿西装并不感到兴奋。老实说，当你把它与及地丝绒长裙、连身裤、妆容和高跟鞋带来的那种惊艳和兴奋感作对比时，它看起来既无聊又吓人。雷满怀敬畏地看着他们的伴侣。我当时就想，哇，管它是什么呢，我当时就觉得，不管那是什么，我都需要它。穿西装似乎很难获得那种特别的盛装打扮的感觉。
Like, sometimes I'm almost underwhelmed when I'm getting dressed. There's just a narrower range of self-expression available to the people who shop in the men's department. We look sort of... Sort of plain and away. Yeah, we're pants every day, and they're the same as the pants that we're yesterday. It's like navy pants. And then I feel like playing on the outside
比如，有时我盛装打扮时几乎会感到有些失落。在男装区购物的人可供选择的自我表达范围实在太窄了。我们看起来有点……有点平淡无奇，千篇一律。是的，我们每天都穿裤子，而且和昨天穿的裤子一模一样。就像深蓝色裤子一样。然后我觉得自己在外面中规中矩，
and then like a complete freak on the inside. And there's a part of me that is tempted to bring the way I feel into how I actually dress myself. As Ray would find out, expression is possible. It's just that menswear doesn't shout. It whispers. And you have to lean in close to hear it. ["Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun It's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mmm. And that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore.
而在内心深处却像个彻底的怪胎。我内心深处有一种冲动，想把我真实的感受融入到我的实际穿着中。正如雷后来所发现的那样，自我表达是完全可能的。只是男装不会大声喧哗。它只是在低语。而你必须凑得很近才能听清。这是幻想。这总是一种你需要付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯。这真是太棒了。现在没有人会像国王那样穿着打扮了。
How do you make money? That's how we make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries. Listen, I love fashion. Made a whole podcast about it. But for a long time, I did not get menswear, specifically suits.
你是怎么赚钱的？我们就是这样赚钱的，亲爱的。有很多我们习以为常的东西，在过去曾被认为是奢侈品。听着，我热爱时尚。我还为此做了一整档播客。但在很长一段时间里，我不理解男装，尤其是西装。
Like, they are neither useful nor interesting. You know what I mean? The jacket doesn't keep you warm. The tie is just kind of a shitty scarf. The pocket square is a hankerchief you don't use. And yet, they all more or less look the same. And that's all men are allowed to wear. You know, during a ward season, fashion journalists
比如，它们既不实用，也没有意思。你知道我的意思吗？夹克不能保暖。领带其实也就是一条糟糕的围巾。口袋巾只是一块你根本不会用的手帕。然而，它们的款式大同小异。而这也是男人们唯一被允许穿的衣服。你知道的，在颁奖季期间，时尚记者们
will highlight the best dressed, and it always includes a bunch of men. You got Brad Pitt, Eddie Murphy, Leo de Caprio. And for the most part, they're all just wearing tuxes. I mean, it's nice, it's nice, they look nice. But it's a black jacket and black pants. On the red carpet, in this world of infinite possibilities where a woman can come in wearing a swan,
会盘点最佳着装，其中总少不了一群男士。有布拉德·皮特、艾迪·墨菲、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。而且大多数时候，他们都只是穿着燕尾服。我的意思是，这很好，这很好，他们看起来很帅。但这只是一件黑色夹克和一条黑色裤子。在红毯上，在这个充满无限可能的世界里，女人可以穿着一件天鹅装出席，
these famous guys are lauded for wearing a black jacket and black pants. Men's wear is hopelessly boring. Sorry, it is. I don't want to use the word boring either, but it's meant to be that way. This is iconic menswear writer G. Bruce Boyer. It's meant to be a uniform.
这些名流却因为穿着黑色夹克和黑色裤子而受到赞誉。男装无聊透顶。抱歉，事实确实如此。我其实也不想用“无聊”这个词，但它生来就是这样的。这位是标志性的男装作家G·布鲁斯·博耶 (G. Bruce Boyer)。它生来就是一种制服。
You know, uniforms keep people in, keep people out. Because of the uniformity of suits, tiny differences make a big statement. Like, it matters if the threading on the button is a certain color. If you have pleats, suits quietly, secretly contain this infinite, ever-shifting world of tiny details. Some are useful, some are purely decorative, but they're all very subtle. These are handmade trousers.
你知道的，制服能把某些人留在圈内，把另一些人挡在圈外。正因为西装千篇一律，所以微小的差异就能表达出强烈的个性。比如，纽扣上的缝线是什么颜色的就很重要。如果你穿的是有褶裤，西装静静地、秘密地包含着这个无限且不断变化的微小细节的世界。有些是有用的，有些纯粹是装饰性的，但它们都非常微妙。这是手工制作的长裤。
The pocket is not on the seam, it's slanted forward, because that way it's easier to get your hand in an app. See, most people wouldn't notice that. But that happens to be an important little detail, an important little detail, an important little detail. Another important little detail, the buttons on the sleeve. If you bought a fancy suit, the buttons are actually functional. So you can actually button the sleeve and unbutton it. You can roll up the sleeve and wash your hands without taking your jacket off. Nice. It's just a little detail. It's a little detail. An important little detail. It's a little detail. Nice. But that's the kind of thing. The suit is an Easter egg hunt for tiny details.
口袋不在侧缝上，而是向前倾斜的，因为这样更容易把手伸进去。你看，大多数人不会注意到这一点。但这恰好是一个重要的小细节，一个重要的小细节，一个重要小细节。另一个重要的小细节，袖口上的纽扣。如果你买了一套昂贵的西装，这些纽扣其实是具有实际功能的。所以你真的可以扣上袖子或者解开袖子。你可以卷起袖子洗手，而不用脱下西装外套。不错。这只是个小细节。这是一个小细节。一个重要的小细节。这是一个小细节。不错。但这就是那种东西。西装就像是一场寻找微小细节的复活节彩蛋游戏。
And there's no way you could ever find all the eggs because some of them are hidden very well. You see that? That little tab? Yeah. It's a little tab. It basically keeps your collar from curling up in the heat. That's a very important little detail that nobody will notice except you.
而且你根本不可能找到所有的彩蛋，因为有些彩蛋藏得非常好。看到那个了吗？那个小标签？对。这是一个小标签。它基本上可以防止你的衣领在炎热的天气里向上翻卷。这是一个非常重要的小细节，除了你自己，没人会注意到。
Nice. We are not looking at Bruce's closet, although it feels like it. It's kind of my home away from home. We're in a store in the Tribeca neighborhood of Manhattan called the Armory. If I say, you know, well, I'm going to be in Manhattan today. My wife has said, you're going to stop there at the Armory, aren't you? I said, well, maybe I will.
不错。我们现在不是在参观布鲁斯的衣帽间，尽管感觉确实如此。这可以说是我的第二个家。我们在曼哈顿翠贝卡 (Tribeca) 社区的一家名为“军械库”(The Armory) 的店里。如果我说，你知道的，嗯，我今天要在曼哈顿。我太太就会说：“你今天会顺便去那家军械库，对吧？”我说：“好吧，也许我会去吧。”
She said, give me your credit cards. The armory is a shop, but it is also basically a clubhouse for menswear nerds, for gentlemen who understand the little clues that make this otherwise plain looking clothing very expensive. What makes these ties special? If you're looking from 10 feet away, nothing. It's when you get up close and you notice that this is a really, these things are very
她说：“把你的信用卡交出来。”军械库是一家商店，但它基本上也是男装迷的俱乐部，是那些懂得欣赏微小细节的绅士们的聚会场所，正是这些细节让这件原本看起来平平无奇的衣服变得极其昂贵。是什么让这些领带如此特别？如果你从 10 英尺外看，什么也看不出来。只有当你走近时，你才会注意到这真的是一根……这些东西非常
subtle, I think. Quality is hard to describe. It comes with experience. And in this way, buying a suit is kind of like ordering a fine wine. The act of purchasing it is itself luxurious because it means you have the time and refinement to learn about what makes a wine good and learn what you like. I mean what we're talking about is quality in the product. You know, and that's really to my mind what luxury is. It's the understanding of quality.
微妙，我认为。品质是很难描述的。它需要经验的积累。从这个意义上说，买西装有点像点一杯高档葡萄酒。购买它的行为本身就是一种奢侈，因为这意味着你有时间和品位去了解是什么让一款葡萄酒变得优秀，并了解你自己的喜好。我的意思是，我们在谈论的是产品的品质。你知道的，这在我看来才是真正的奢侈品。它是对品质的理解。
In menswear that understanding of quality invites a degree of machismo. A lot of the fashion nerd guys are all sizing each other up over these little details. Is your pocket slanted? How many vents does your jacket have? How's your pocket square folded? Who made your shoes? It's a blood sport with them. It's a kind of one-upmanship. That's the going to size you up right away. Part of me is like, uh, boys, boys, don't make it a competition. It's a blood sport
在男装领域，这种对品质的理解会激发出一定程度的大男子主义。许多时尚极客们都在通过这些微小细节暗中打量对方。你的口袋是斜的吗？你的夹克有几个开衩？你的口袋巾是怎么折的？你的鞋子是谁做的？对他们来说，这是一场血腥的运动。这是一种好胜心。那是会立刻将你打量一番的做法。我内心的一部分会想：噢，男孩们，男孩们，别把它变成一场竞赛。这是一场血腥的运动。
Although unlike other blood sports like cars or fine wines or whatever dudes can turn into a dick measuring contest menswear has this strange X factor Sprezzatura Sprezzatura Yes, good. Sprezzatura Italian go figure means a studied carelessness Satura, Italian, go figure, means a studied carelessness. It's this concept that you're not supposed to look like you put a lot of effort into
尽管与其他汽车或高级葡萄酒等容易让直男们变成一场“比大”竞赛的血腥运动不同，男装有着一个奇怪的 X 因素——随性（Sprezzatura）。Sprezzatura？是的，很好。Sprezzatura，意大利语，你猜怎么着，意思是“刻意的随性”。Sprezzatura，意大利语，你猜怎么着，意思是刻意的随性。这个概念就是，你明明花了很多心思，
the way you dress, even though you probably did. Because it's not cool for men to care about how they look. That's the... The spiritual shore of life. You know, you see a guy and you say, oh well, the buttons of his shirt aren't buttoned. He knows that. He knows that. He knows that. You're not telling him anything. Real men's wear buffs will say, you don't want to look too crisp and clean and buttoned up. Otherwise, you look too slick, like you're
却要让人看起来好像没怎么费心打扮过，尽管你很可能费了不少心思。因为对于男人来说，在意自己的外表并不是一件很酷的事。那就是……生活的精神彼岸。你知道的，你看到一个男人，然后你会说，哦，他的衬衫扣子没扣好。他是故意这样的。他知道这一点。他知道这一点。你什么都不用提醒他。真正的男装发烧友会说，你可不想让自己看起来过于一丝不苟、干净整洁且扣得严严实实。否则，你会显得太油滑，就像一个
a butler or something. You got to give it a little spratatura. If his tie is crooked, he put it that way. You know, if he left his sleep buttons undone, he did that on purpose. He knows that. You're not telling him anything, believe me. The idea he wants to get across to you is that he looks fabulous. And if he cared just a little bit more,
管家什么的。你得表现出一点随性。如果他的领带是歪的，他是故意弄成那样的。你知道的，如果他把袖扣解开，他也是故意这么做的。他知道这一点。相信我，你不用提醒他任何事。他想向你传达的理念是，他看起来棒极了。只要他再稍微多花一点心思，
if he straightened his tie, if he buttoned his buttons, he would really look terrific. He knows that, he knows that. It shows a strength held in reserve. And so there's this illusion that well-dressed men are the chosen ones who are just effortlessly elegant. Like either you have the right stuff or you don't. So a lot of men don't really try.
只要他把领带扶正，只要他把扣子扣好，他就会真的帅呆了。他知道这一点，他知道这一点。这展现了一种有所保留的力量。因此，这就产生了一种错觉，即衣着优雅的男士都是天选之子，他们只是毫不费力地展现出优雅。就好像要么你天生有这种品味，要么就没有。所以很多男人根本懒得去尝试。
Many of them grew up without learning how to shop for clothes, without taking the time to figure out their taste and their bodies. Because again, they weren't supposed to care. And this, all of this, everything about menswear from the uniformity to the world of tiny details to this whole culture of Sprezzatura, a lot of it can be traced back to one man. One man. His name was Bo Brummel. Always a joy to talk about Brummel.
他们中的许多人在成长过程中没有学会如何购买衣服，没有花时间去摸索自己的品味和体型。因为同样地，他们被认为不应该去在意这些。而这一切——男装的一切，从千篇一律的制服到微小细节的世界，再到整个“随性”文化——其中很大一部分都可以追溯到一个男人。一个男人。他的名字叫博·布鲁梅尔 (Bo Brummel)。谈论布鲁梅尔总是令人愉快的。
Ian Kelly is a historian, screenwriter, and playwright. He's also, by the way, an accomplished actor. And yes, I do play Hermione's father in the Harry Potter movies. I think you've instantly undermined whatever academic cred I might have had. No, no, no, no, it's so impressive. Ian Kelly is absolutely a guy with academic cred. This muggle wrote the definitive biography of Bob Rommel, who was bopping around London at the turn of the 19th century. Before Bo, men and women at the highest echelons of the European court systems used to dress
伊恩·凯利 (Ian Kelly) 是一位历史学家、编剧兼剧作家。顺便说一句，他也是一位成就斐然的演员。没错，我在《哈利·波特》电影里饰演赫敏的父亲。我想你这么一说，瞬间就削弱了我可能拥有的任何学术信誉。不，不，不，不，这太令人印象深刻了。伊恩·凯利绝对是一个极具学术信誉的人。这个麻瓜写了博·布鲁梅尔的权威传记，这位老兄在 19 世纪之交时在伦敦混得风生水起。在博出现之前，欧洲宫廷体系最高阶层的男女通常穿着
in kind of the same way. Everyone had white powdered faces and wigs and big lacy callers and high heels, dripping with rich fabrics and rare gemstones. Everyone, men and women were decking themselves out elaborately and glamourously. And then there was a massive shift. What fashion historians called the great male renunciation.
几乎同样的服饰。每个人都涂着白粉脸，戴着假发，穿着带有巨大蕾丝花边的领饰和高阶高跟鞋，浑身挂满华丽的面料和珍稀的宝石。每个人，无论男女，都把自己装扮得精致而迷人。然后，发生了一次巨大的转变。时尚史学家称之为“伟大男装放弃潮”。
The great male renunciation. The moment when men's fashion foregoes, pretty much forever, lace and silk and feathers and wigs and makeup and colour and goes for something quite paired down. And this renunciation in many ways started with a bow. At its simplest, I should say, a bow rumble is the bigeta of the suit. The suit, as we know it, did not exist before bow rumble. I know you thought I was being a reductionist history podcaster when I was like, it all began with one man, but it's really true.
伟大男装放弃潮。男士时尚几乎永远地抛弃了蕾丝、丝绸、羽毛、假发、妆容和色彩，转而选择一种极为简约风格的时刻。而这种放弃在很多方面都是从一个蝴蝶结开始的。简单来说，我应该说，博·布鲁梅尔是西装的鼻祖。我们所知的西装，在博·布鲁梅尔之前是不存在的。我知道当我表现得像个喜欢搞历史决定论的播客主持人，说这一切都始于一个男人时，你可能会觉得我在搞简单化，但这千真万确。
Bo Brummel changed everything. I'll keep the most important single figure in the whole history of fashion. What Adam Smith was to economics, what Charles Darwin was to biology, Bo Brummel was to fashion. Although unlike other founders of the modern era, Bo was wildly unqualified.
博·布鲁梅尔改变了一切。我认为他是整个时尚史上最重要的人物。亚当·斯密对经济学的意义，查尔斯·达尔文对生物学的意义，博·布鲁梅尔对时尚就是这样的意义。尽管与其他现代时期的开创者不同，博完全不够资格。
He wasn't a fashion designer. He wasn't a tailor. He wasn't even a nobleman. He was for one of the better words, a celebrity. He was kind of famous for being famous. Today we would call Bo Brummel an influencer. He was rich, he was funny, he was charming, he was good looking, hence bow.
他不是时装设计师。他不是裁缝。他甚至不是贵族。如果换个更好听的词来说，他是一个名人。他因为出名而闻名。今天我们会把博·布鲁梅尔称为网红。他很有钱，很有趣，很有魅力，长得很帅，因此得名“博”。
Chai-bu. Bow was his nickname, but before he grew up to be hot, he was born George Brummel in 1778, and his parents were servants. His parents working for Lord North, who used to go down until very recently as the least successful Prime Minister in British history, now with somewhat stiff competition, but he famously lost the American colonies. Bo's father was Lord North's private secretary, and made an unusually large amount of money in that job. It was what was known in the 18th century as peculation, which I think now we call embezzlement.
小名博。博是他的昵称，但在他变得性感迷人之前，他于 1778 年出生，原名乔治·布鲁梅尔，他的父母是仆人。他的父母为诺思勋爵 (Lord North) 工作，直到最近，他一直被认为英国历史上最不成功的首相，现在虽然有了一些强有力的竞争对手，但他最著名的“功绩”是丢掉了美洲殖民地。博的父亲是诺思勋爵的私人秘书，并在这份工作中赚取了异常巨额的财富。这在 18 世纪被称为“贪污挪用”，我想现在我们称之为侵占公款。
And so Bo grew up around wealth. He was accustomed to it. He went to fancy schools. He knew all the right people. And when his parents died when he was a teenager, he inherited the family fortune. Bo mostly spent his days gambling and going to the theater and just being handsome and witty. Famous initially for being the wittiest man in London.
因此，博在财富环绕的环境中长大。他对这一切习以为常。他上了贵族学校。他认识所有对的人。当他的父母在他十几岁时双双去世后，他继承了家族财产。博的日子基本上就是在赌博、看戏剧中度过，长得帅气又机智。最初因为是伦敦最机智的男人而闻名。
Reading his quotes, I don't know if I would call him witty as much as I would call him mean. To give you an idea, here's a classic bowbrumble zinger. So bow comes up to some Lord on the street and asks him, What are those things on your feet? This Lord, of course, said their shoes, bow reply. He thought they were slippers.
读着他的名言，我不知道该说他是机智还是刻薄。为了让你有个概念，这里有一个博·布鲁梅尔式的经典讽刺金句。有一次，博在街上走到一位勋爵面前问他：“你脚上穿的那些是什么东西？”这位勋爵当然回答说是鞋子，博却回答说。他以为那是拖鞋。
I thought they were slippers. Ooh, burn. Apparently this kind of insult humor went over very well and Bo roamed the streets of London just dispensing clever insults and looking great. Trat, trat, trat, boo. But Bo Brummel's style was shockingly simple. He wore the same thing every single day. A white shirt, a dark jacket, and tan pants. This look was the grandfather of the suit. And as conventional and stuffy as we may think of the suit today, those look was absolutely rebellious and unprecedented. For one thing, pants were pretty wild. That is you a full length cylinder of cloth from crotch to floor was very unusual before
我以为那是拖鞋。哦，真是神补刀。显然，这种讽刺幽默非常吃香，博在伦敦街头游荡，四处抛出聪明的讽刺，同时外表光鲜亮丽。哒，哒，哒，博。但博·布鲁梅尔的风格却出奇的简单。他每天都穿同样的衣服：一件白衬衫、一件深色夹克和一条黄褐色裤子。这种造型是西装的鼻祖。尽管我们今天可能会觉得西装既传统又死板，但当时的这种造型绝对是离经叛道且史无前例的。首先，穿裤子是一件相当疯狂的事。也就是说，在博·布鲁梅尔之前，从胯部到脚踝由一块完整的布料制成的圆筒形裤子是非常罕见的。
bowbrumble. I per class men used to wear things that kind of look like shorts or maybe petal pushers with socks or stockings, just these bottoms that had multiple layers and parts to them. But bows long, shapely legs were accentuated by one uninterrupted piece of cloth. And Bose pants were really, really tight, really tight. Bose required an assistant to get his pants on. There is this fashion in wake of Bob Romul of wearing punishingly tight, usually rather pale trousers, and indeed in an era when gentlemen
中产阶级以上的男士过去常常穿着看起来像短裤或踩脚裤的衣服，搭配短袜或长袜，这些下装有多层和多个部件。但博那修长匀称的双腿被一块连贯的布料完美勾勒出来。而且博的裤子真的非常非常紧，紧得离谱。博需要一个助理才能把裤子穿上。在博·布鲁梅尔之后，流行起穿那种紧绷得折磨人、通常颜色相当苍白的裤子的风潮，事实上，在一个绅士们
did not wear undergarments of any sort, for fear of what I believe is known as visible pantyline. These early bobe rumble pants made men look nearly naked, like they were Donald ducking it, and this was intentional. It was inspired by this widespread obsession with Greco-Roman Statuary. A fascination with the art of the ancients and in particular with sculpture.
绝不穿任何内衣的时代里，因为害怕出现我所认为的所谓的“内裤痕迹”。这些早期的博·布鲁梅尔式裤子让男人们看起来几乎赤身裸体，就像唐老鸭那样下半身光着，而这完全是刻意的。这是受到当时对希腊罗马雕塑的广泛痴迷所启发的。对古代艺术尤其是雕塑的着迷。
Think of Jane Austen movies, right? Women around Bob Rommel's time curled their hair and pinned it back low and wore simple white gowns that made them look like statues of Greek goddesses. But Greek and Roman male statues were almost invariably nude, or at least the ones that were considered a far-tistic import, and the origins of tailoring is born strangely in emulation of a sort of a nudity. Tailoring was also an emulation of a military look. The suit jacket was derived from a riding outfit, Beau Bramble had served in the cavalry.
想想简·奥斯汀的电影，对吧？博·布鲁梅尔时期的女性把头发烫卷并在脑后低低盘起，穿着简单的白色长裙，让她们看起来就像希腊女神的雕像。但希腊和罗马的男性雕像几乎无一例外都是赤裸的，或者至少那些被认为具有艺术价值的是这样的。剪裁的起源奇怪地诞生于对某种裸露状态的模仿。剪裁也是对军装外观的一种模仿。西装夹克源自骑马装，博·布鲁梅尔曾在骑兵部队服役。
The monochrome, the simplicity, has its illusion to military uniform, but also the idea of uniformity. Having a uniform allows people to feel part of some larger cause, or part of a club. And so, when Beau dressed in the same way every single day, he amassed followers. And they proudly called themselves dandies. Dandie didn't mean how we think of it today. Then it meant edgy and minimal and extremely heterosexual, this manly cohort of men who slavishly followed bow and dressed just like him.
单色调和简约风，既暗指了军装，也体现了制服的理念。拥有一定制服能让人们感到自己是某个更宏大事业或某个俱乐部的一部分。因此，当博每天都穿着同样的衣服时，他积聚了一批追随者。他们自豪地自称为“花花公子”(dandies)。当时的 dandy 并不是我们今天理解的意思。当时它意味着前卫、极简且极度异性恋，这是一个盲目崇拜博并模仿他穿衣打扮的阳刚男性群体。
He's the central personality cult, really, the dandies of the West End, who began dressing in this strict, pared-down, militaristic monochrome. But bear in mind, Bo wasn't dressing like his own country's military. This is, after all, in the wake of the American Revolution, the Brits had fought and lost, wearing their bright red coats with flashy gold buttons and long tails and fancy hats. The rebels, the victorious underdog colonists, were clad in muted blues and graze. Bo was dressing like the rebels. The dress down issue of, though Bromland, his friends, was sometimes taken as looking in support of or in allusion to American revolutionaries or French revolutionaries, very dressed down, very, you know, man-of-the-people
他实际上是一个核心个人崇拜的对象，即西区那些开始穿着这种严谨、简朴、军事化单色调服饰的花花公子们。但请记住，博穿得并不像他自己国家的军队。毕竟，这是在美国独立战争之后，英国人经历了战斗并战败了，他们当时穿着鲜红的外套，带有耀眼的金色纽扣、长长的燕尾服和华丽的帽子。而那些叛军，也就是获得胜利的处于劣势的殖民地人民，穿的是柔和的蓝色和灰色。博的穿着打扮就像那些叛军一样。博·布鲁梅尔和他的朋友们的这种随意着装，有时被视为支持或暗指美国革命者或法国革命者，那种非常随意的、你知道的“平民化”的
sort of look. Because the trajectory of what created the suit and what drives fashion forward has always been the need for more democratic, simpler, dressed down, relatable, close. This is Derek Guy, one of my favorite fashion writers and editor for the website put this on. If the Brits didn't take over the world, and if Brumel had never lived, would we still have the suit without Brumel, I think undoubtedly yes. The great male renunciation kicked off with Brumel, for sure. The great male renunciation. But Brumel was channeling forces larger than himself, and sentiments that were brewing long before he was born.
风格。因为创造西装的发展轨迹以及推动时尚不断向前的动力，始终是对更加民主、更简单、更随意、更接地气的服装的需求。这是德里克·盖伊 (Derek Guy)，我最喜欢的时尚作家之一，也是网站“Put This On”的编辑。如果英国人没有征服世界，如果布鲁梅尔从未存在过，如果没有布鲁梅尔，我们还会拥有西装吗？我认为毫无疑问是会的。伟大男装放弃潮确实随着布鲁梅尔拉开了序幕。伟大男装放弃潮。但布鲁梅尔顺应的力量远比他自身更宏大，这些情绪在他出生很久之前就已经在酝酿了。
Think about it. For centuries, Western monarchs and upper-crest courtly people looked like goddamn aliens. Elizabeth I dressed in a silhouette that almost made her look like an insect. She had a very, very narrow corset made out of well bones. I mean, her garments were made out of wood, baling, velvet, these kind of like gauzy silks that would float around her head, look like dry ice. And the idea
想想看。几个世纪以来，西方的君主和上流社会的宫廷人士看起来就像该死的外星人。伊丽莎白一世的穿着轮廓甚至让她看起来像一只昆虫。她穿着一件用鲸骨制成的非常非常窄的紧身胸衣。我的意思是，她的衣服是由木头、鲸须、天鹅绒以及那些会在她头顶飘浮、看起来像干冰一般的薄纱制成的。当时那种服装的
of that dress at the time was to establish her position on the throne and the institution of mon G itself. This look was otherworldly, intentionally saying, I am not like you. If you had at any point thought that this person was just a human being like you, then what justifies their rule over this entire kingdom? But things started to change after Queen Elizabeth
理念是为了确立她在王位上的地位以及君主制机构本身。这种造型超凡脱俗，刻意在说：我和你们不一样。如果你在任何时候认为这个人只是一个和你一样的人类，那么有什么能为他们统治整个王国的合法性辩护呢？但这种情况在伊丽莎白女王之后的查理一世统治时期开始发生改变。查理一世也有一衣柜极其奢华的服装。此时的不同之处在于印刷术的兴起。印刷术在伊丽莎白时期就已经存在，但在查理一世统治时期真正开始腾飞，这意味着皇室子民可以——并且确实——印刷了各种小册子，让查理大帝穿着他那带有巨大蕾丝衣领的衣服看起来滑稽透顶。基本上，他们制作了政治漫画。是的，就是政治漫画，完全正确。所以你以为那是一顶奢华的帽子，而在他们眼里那是一顶傻气的帽子。
during the reign of Charles I. Charles I also had a very extravagant wardrobe. The difference at this time is that you had the rise of the printing press. The printing press was a round in Elizabethan times, but it really started to take off under Charles I, which meant royal subjects could, and did, print pamphlets making Charles look absolutely ridiculous in his big lacy callers. Basically, they made political cartoons. Yeah, political cartoons, exactly. So what you think is an extravagant hat, they would show as a silly hat.
这也为其他的批评打开了大门。当人们开始批评你的衣服时，他们就会开始批评你的品格和你的消费习惯。果不其然，查理那疯狂的服装促使议会质疑他管理资金不善的种种其他方式，而事实证明这些问题层出不穷。这与当时日益高涨的自由主义思想有关。当这个社会的商人群体正在崛起、获得权力和开始质疑时，这些人怎么还能穿着黄金到处走？你穿着这些东西在干什么？你用我的钱在做什么？
And it opened up the doors for other criticisms. When people start criticizing your clothes, and they start criticizing your character and your spending habits. Sure enough, Charles' crazy clothes led Parliament to question all the other ways he had mismanaged his funds, which it turned out were manifold. It has to do with the growing ideas of liberalism at the time. How would these people be walking around wearing gold when the merchant class in that society was rising, gaining power, and started questioning, why are you wearing all that stuff? What are you doing with my money?
通过这种方式，拥有财富和权力的男人们慢慢意识到，最好把底牌藏在心底，不要冒着看起来荒谬或轻浮的风险。在自由主义的高涨浪潮中，权力和财富变成了克制与距离感。而布鲁梅尔的西装完美地满足了这种渴望，因为它表面上看起来很民主，但却静静地散发着财富的气息。
And in this way, men of wealth and power slowly realized it was best to keep their cards close to their vests, to not risk looking ridiculous or frivolous. In the rising tide of liberalism, power and wealth became about restraint and distance. And Brumel's suit fulfilled this desire perfectly because it was democratic on its surface, but it quietly oozed wealth.
如果你不打算依靠浮华来确立自己的地位，那么这就关系到完美的细节。而细节是多方面的。而细节是多种多样的。而且细节价格不菲，西装需要无可挑剔的剪裁，你还得雇一个男仆来帮你穿上紧身裤，博开创了在夹克里面穿一件挺括白衬衫的潮流。通过干净的白色亚麻织物来彰显财富和特权，这是一种很有意思的暗示。在 18 世纪的伦敦，如果不把衣服弄得
If you're not going to rely on bling to establish your status then it's to do with perfect detail. And the details were various detail and the details were various. And the details were expensive, the suit required flawless tailoring and you had to hire a valet to help you into your tight pants and both started the trend of wearing a crisp white shirt under your jacket. There's an interesting signaling of wealth and privilege through clean white linen. It was impossible to dry clothes in 18th century London without getting them
满是煤烟，是不可能把衣服晾干的。为了让白衬衫和领结真正保持洁净，博不得不把他的洗涤工作送到乡下去。因此，仅仅拥有干净的白色亚麻织物就是财富的象征，也是注重细节的表现。男人们对博的微小细节世界着迷不已，为了理解他这种新的穿衣方式，每天早上都会有人群聚集在博的房子外面，观看博做准备。由于他名气太大，人们会来看他穿衣服。他可能有一些强迫症倾向，他花了好几个小时穿衣服，其中一个多小时都是赤身裸体地站在他的一帮朋友面前，其中包括威尔士亲王。我怎么强调都不为过，威尔士亲王竟然在观看博·布鲁梅尔穿衣，以此来学习如何像一个平民那样穿衣，学习如何穿得好像他根本不在乎
covered in suit. To get white shirts and cravats truly clean, Bo had to send his laundry out to the countryside. So the issue of just having clean white linen is a signifier of wealth and just having clean white linen is a signifier of wealth and an attention to detail. Men were fascinated by Bose world of tiny details, and to understand his new way of dressing, actual crowds would gather at Bose house every morning to watch Bose get ready. Such was his celebrity people would come to watch him dress. He possibly had some sort of OCD issue in that he took several hours to dress, an hour or more of it naked in front of his assorted friends, including the Prince of Wales. I cannot emphasize how crazy it was that the Prince of Wales was watching Bo Rommel in order to learn how to dress like a commoner, to learn to dress as though he did not care
如何穿衣一样，这实在是太疯狂了。观众们看着博一次又一次地系好又解开他的领结，直到它看起来像是他刚刚轻快而毫不费力地系好的一样。正如博的一位花花公子追随者所写的那样：“我的领结花了我好几个小时的焦躁不安，才让它看起来像是匆忙系好的。”因为真正的男人穿着随意，真正的男人不在乎。博的花花公子风格一直主导着伦敦时尚界，直到 1812 年，他的讽刺幽默太过火了。
about dressing. The audience watched as Bo famously tied and retied his cravat over and over again until it appeared as though he had just tied it briskly and effortlessly. As one of Bo's dandy followers wrote, my neck cloth cost me some hours of flurry to make it appear to be tied in a hurry. Because real men dress down, and real men don't care. Bose Dandyism had a grip on the London scene until 1812 when his insult comedy went step too far.
他在摄政王面前，对他们俩的一个共同朋友说了一句相当惊艳的话，从而公开侮辱了威尔士亲王。谁是你那个胖朋友？谁是你那个胖朋友？威尔士亲王对自己的体重很敏感，这番话相当恶劣，即使对博来说也是如此。他很快就失去了上流社会的青睐，随后英国经历了一场严重的经济衰退，博·布鲁梅尔背上了巨额债务。于是他逃到了法国，在那里精神失常并死于梅毒，这实际上反而加剧了世人对他作为一个悲剧性、迷人人物的神话色彩。博·布鲁梅尔的影响深远。正如布鲁梅尔精辟地指出的那样：
He publicly insulted the Prince of Wales with the rather fabulous line to a mutual friend of theirs in front of the Prince Regent. Who's your fat friend? Who's your fat friend? The Prince of Wales was sensitive about his weight and this was pretty nasty, even for Beau. He fell out of favor with high society quickly and then Britain went through a serious recession and Beau Brummel was in a lot of debt. And so he fled to France, where he went mad and died of syphilis, which actually heightened the mythology of him as this tragic, glamorous figure. Beau Brummel's influence was profound. As Brummel so concisely said,
要真正做到优雅，就不应该引人注目。这差不多就是现在男装领域的金科玉律。但整个转变并没有在博·布鲁梅尔的有生之年发生。正如你从生活在这个世界上所了解到的那样，有些人追随潮流，有些人则不然。伟大男士放弃潮直到将近一个世纪后才真正全面确立，而推动这一转变的人物在很多方面与布鲁梅尔相当相似。奥斯卡·王尔德。奥斯卡·王尔德的《道林·格雷的画像》最初在法国出版时，被评论和撰文
To be truly elegant, one should not be noticed. This is more or less the rule of law in menswear now. But the whole shift didn't happen within Bobrommel's lifetime. As you know from living in the world, some people follow trends, some people don't. The great male renunciation didn't fully take hold until nearly a century later, with a figure who, in a lot of ways, was quite similar to Brummel. Oscar Wilde. Oscar Wilde's Dorian Gray, when it was first published in France, was reviewed and written
视为一则关于博·布鲁梅尔的寓言或是关于梅毒的寓言。奥斯卡·王尔德对博·布鲁梅尔着迷不已。和博·布鲁梅尔一样，奥斯卡·王尔德也是伦敦社交界一个妙语连珠的人，经常出入剧院并津津乐道于机智的反击。但在最重要的一点上，他与布鲁梅尔截然不同。奥斯卡·王尔德是一个穿着极其张扬的人。
of as a parable about Bobrummel or a parable about Cifilis. Oscar Wilde was obsessed with Bobrummel. And like Bobrummel, Oscar Wilde was also a witty man about London, frequenting the theater and vending about clever retorts. But he was emphatically unlike Brommel in the most important way. Oscar Wilde was a really flamboyant dresser.
他穿斗篷、巨大的帽子、天鹅绒服装。我的意思是，他的穿着非常奢华，当时他把服装作为一种建立自己的媒体曝光度和公众形象的方式。因此，比方说当他为戏剧进行巡回演出时，无论是在舞台上还是在私下生活中，他都会精心打扮，而媒体会报道他，这当然有助于宣传他的戏剧。
He wore capes, these huge hats, velvet. I mean, he was dressed very extravagantly and he used at the time clothes as a way to build up his press and characters. So when he would go on tours for plays, for example, he would dress up both on stage and in private life and the press would write about him, which of course helped advertise his plays.
奥斯卡·王尔德被怀疑是同性恋，随后因涉嫌同性恋而闻名遐迩地受审。由于他的性取向，他被判入狱两年。这给浮华的着装泼了一盆冷水。现在可是有真正的利益风险了。如果看起来像奥斯卡·王尔德可能会被当成犯罪，那为什么还要冒这个险呢？德里克·盖伊认为，正是奥斯卡·王尔德的审判在许多方面给“伟大男装放弃潮”盖棺定论。也许最好还是不要引人注目，
Oscar Wilde was suspected of being gay and then famously was put on trial for it. And he was sent to prison for two years for his sexuality. This threw a bucket of cold water on flamboyant dressing. There were real stakes now. If looking like Oscar Wilde could be taken for a crime, why risk it? Derek Guy argues that it was the trial of Oscar Wilde that, in many ways, sealed the fate of the great male renunciation. Maybe it was best to not be noticed,
不要在乎衣服，这样你的穿着就不会吸引人们对你如何花钱或你在和谁发生性关系的关注。也许对于男人们来说，穿灰色、蓝色和黑色的衣服，并且只在微小的细节中表达自我，才是明智之举。这在西方一直是长久以来的铁律，以至于这种神话似乎让人无法摆脱。我的意思是，曾经在 Styleforum 这个专门供对服装感兴趣的男士交流的在线论坛上，
to not care about clothes, so that what you wear doesn't call attention to the way you spend your money or who you're having sex with. Perhaps it was smart for men to dress in gray and blue and black, and to express themselves only in small details. This has been the rule in the West for so long this mythology seems impossible to break out of. I mean, there was a time on style form, which is an online form for men who are interested in clothing, where recently it's the late Aughts mid Aughts where people would routinely post,
最近大约是在 21 世纪 00 年代末到 05 年代中期，人们经常发帖问：
is it okay for me to wear a pink shirt? Does it make me less manly? That, unfortunately, I think, is part of this long shadow of Oscar Wilde's trial and how men are very worried about what an interesting clothing means for how people perceive their manliness. Of course, throughout the history of men's fashion,
我穿粉红色衬衫可以吗？这会让我显得不那么有男人味吗？不幸的是，我认为这正是奥斯卡·王尔德受审所投下的漫长阴影的一部分，它体现了男人们是多么担心有趣的服装会如何影响人们对他们男子气概的看法。当然，在男士时尚的历史上，
there have been notable exceptions, like the peacock revolution of the 1960s and 70s, when men were in psychedelic patterns and chunky high heels. Not to mention the many varied and exciting versions of menswear that persist beyond Bose Western European model. And now there are these modern trailblazers, like Billy Porter and Harry Styles, who are really trying to have fun with clothes.
也曾出现过一些显著的例外，比如 20 世纪 60 年代和 70 年代的孔雀革命，当时男士们穿着迷幻图案和厚底高跟鞋。更不用说在博的西欧模范之外依然存在的许多丰富多变且令人兴奋的男装版本了。现在，还有比利·波特 (Billy Porter) 和哈里·斯泰尔斯 (Harry Styles) 这样的现代先锋人物，他们真的在努力从服装中寻找乐趣。
Men are slowly learning to get more comfortable with self-expression, but it's delicate, you know? Even at the armory, that store clubhouse for competitive men's winners, the clothes for sale there are all pretty subdued. It's very traditional clothing, but it's... there's something very interesting about it all, don't you think? I do, but of course, you know, part of me thinks, oh, man, we should liberate men from this realm of small details
男人们正在慢慢学会对自我表达感到更加自在，但这是很微妙的，你知道的？即使在“军械库”那家充满竞争性的男装爱好者的商店俱乐部里，那里出售的衣服也都很低调。这是非常传统的服装，但它……这一切都有着非常有趣的地方，你不觉得吗？我是这么觉得的，但当然，你知道的，我内心的一部分会想，哦，天哪，我们应该把男人们从微小细节的领域解放出来，
and let them wear purple suits, you know? Well, uh, yeah, and that may be true. That may be true. I'm not sure I would even want to argue with that. I mean, I could go the other way with you and say, you know, get away from the tyranny of fashion a little bit. I mean, come on, you're going to change your whole silhouette from one season to another. I mean, let's even talk about the environment.
让他们穿紫色的西装，你知道吗？嗯，呃，是的，这或许是真的。这或许是真的。我不确定我是否会想反驳这一点。我的意思是，我可以从另一个角度跟你探讨，你知道的，稍微摆脱一下时尚的暴政。我的意思是，拜托，你总不能每个季度都要改变你整体的服装轮廓吧。我的意思是，我们甚至可以谈谈环保。
Do she? I guess my answer to the subtlety would be, you get a train your eye a little bit, your little blatant. You don't really have to knock me out with the topless, backless, red thing that you're wearing. I get it. Bruce is speaking hypothetically, I was not wearing a topless, backless red thing. But we could have a little subtlety in the dress too, right? So I mean, I think that kind of thing works both ways, but I wouldn't argue with you about it. No, no, no, that's a really good point.
对吧？我想我对这种微妙感的回答是，你得稍微训练一下你的眼光，你的那些公然炫耀。你其实不必用你身上穿着的那件露胸、露背的红色衣服把我给震慑住。我懂的。布鲁斯是在假设，我当时并没有穿什么露胸、露背的红色衣服。但我们的穿着也可以有一点微妙感，对吧？所以我的意思是，我觉得这种事两方面都说得通，但我不会跟你争论这个。不，不，不，这真是个好观点。
Bruce is bright. A suit is timeless. You can really invest in one and wear it over and over again, and I love that. But I just cringe because suits have traditionally represented this version of macho boring dressing that I've always presented. And I guess the thing is that so much of the power of the suit lies in who is wearing it, and how well it fits them. On one hand, yeah, of course it's the garment of power. But on the other hand, it's just kind of like
布鲁斯很聪明。西装是永恒的。你确实可以投资一套，然后反复穿着它，我非常喜欢这一点。但我还是会感到畏缩，因为西装传统上代表着这种大男子主义的无聊着装，而这正是我一直以来所排斥的。我想关键在于，西装的很大一部分力量在于穿它的人是谁，以及它有多合身。一方面，是的，这当然是权力的服装；但另一方面，它其实也就像
putting a suit on means that I can tap into that power too if I want. That's Ray Teterra, who had to get dressed up for that wedding 10 years ago. And in their hunt for that special dress-up feeling, Ray ended up finding it in a suit. It's kind of like when Dorothy realized she could go home all along after a yellow brick road journey. Ray learned about the world of cut and fit and tiny details and has dedicated their life's work to spreading this knowledge around. Can't suits be fun? Oh, they're so fun!
穿上一套西装意味着如果我愿意，我也能借此汲取那种力量。那是雷·蒂塔拉，10 年前不得不为那场婚礼盛装打扮的人。在寻找那种特别的盛装感觉的过程中，雷最终在一套西装中找到了它。这有点像多萝西在黄砖路之旅后意识到自己其实一直都可以回家一样。雷了解了剪裁、版型和微小细节的世界，并将自己的一生奉献于将这些知识传播开来。西装难道不能很有趣吗？哦，它们太有趣了！
Ray is now a partner at Bindle and Keep, a bespoke tailor in Brooklyn whose motto is suits for everybody. Hold on, I'm gonna grab a suit. It's beautiful, I'll be right back. Ray is very good at their job and instantly pluck the suit off the rack that fit me perfectly. You think this'll fit? Yeah, what's the bring here? I don't think so.
雷现在是布鲁克林一家名为 Bindle and Keep 的定制裁缝店的合伙人，这家店的座右铭是“为所有人定制西装”。等一下，我去拿套西装。这件很好看，我马上回来。雷非常擅长他们的工作，瞬间从衣架上抽出一件非常适合我的西装。你觉得这件会合身吗？对，拿这里来？我不这么觉得。
Yeah, so it'll be fine. I was totally smitten. Ooh. Ooh. It's so good. I don't know, it's wonderful. Why does it fit? Why do I love it somewhere?
对，所以这件会挺合适的。我完全被迷住了。哦。哦。这太棒了。我不知道，这太美妙了。为什么它这么合身？为什么我这么喜欢它？
What's going on? Okay, first thing is, if it's wonderful. Why does it fit? Why do I love it somewhere? What's going on? Okay, first thing is, if it's your shoulder's pretty well. Of course, a well-fitting suit is a privilege and a luxury. But there's a reason the style has stuck around since Bo Goddamn Brummel. If you get one that fits you, everyone can look great in a suit. You're also liking it because the button is closer to the narrowest point on your torso.
到底怎么回事？好吧，第一件事是，它真的很棒。为什么它这么合身？为什么我这么喜欢它？到底怎么回事？好吧，第一件事是，你的肩膀撑得挺好。当然，一套合身的西装是一种特权和奢侈。但这种风格自博·该死的·布鲁梅尔以来一直延续至今是有原因的。如果你买了一件适合自己的西装，每个人都可以穿得很帅。你也喜欢它，是因为纽扣更靠近你躯干最窄的部位。
I mean, yeah, it's proportional to you. I think that's why you like it. Yeah, I liked it a lot. I just hope that we can move to a point in society where more people feel truly comfortable expressing themselves as loudly or as subtly as they would like to, which would be a big shift. But, you know, which would be a big shift. But, you know, look at Bob Rommel. It might only take one extremely well-dressed person
我的意思是，对，它和你的身材比例很协调。我想这就是你喜欢它的原因。对，我很喜欢它。我只希望我们能进入这样一个社会阶段：更多的人能够真正感到自在，按照自己喜欢的大胆或微妙的程度来表达自我，这将是一个巨大的转变。但是，你知道的，看看博·布鲁梅尔。这可能只需要一个极其注重着装的人就能做到。
to change the entire paradigm again. The pocket, the piece of paper The piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love. Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Truffleman, edited by Chris Baroube, scored by Ray Royal, fact checked by Tom Colligan with additional fact checking by Graham Haysha, mixed in tech production by Sharif Yusef, with additional mixing by Catherine Ray Mondo.
再次改变整个范式。口袋，一张纸。一张纸。昨天的词语。在我们热爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。《感兴趣的物品》由埃弗里·特鲁弗曼（Avery Truffleman）编剧和表演，克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）编辑，雷·罗亚尔（Ray Royal）配乐，汤姆·科利根（Tom Colligan）进行事实核查，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）进行额外的事实核查，谢里夫·尤塞夫（Sharif Yusef）负责混音和技术制作，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Catherine Ray Mondo）协助混音。
Our opening and closing songs are by Sassami. Insights support and edits from the whole 99PI team, including Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Sean Rial, Abby Maddon, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle. Special thanks to Fantasy author and podcaster Alex Rowland, who first told me about Bo Brummel in an amazing Twitter thread. Follow them at underscore Alex Rowland.
我们的开场曲和闭幕曲由萨萨米（Sassami）创作。整个99PI团队提供了见解支持和编辑，包括乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·莱伊（Vivian Leigh）、肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）、艾比·马登（Abby Maddon）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。特别感谢奇幻作家兼播客亚历克斯·罗兰（Alex Rowland），他最初在一篇精彩的推特长文中向我介绍了博·布鲁梅尔（Bo Brummel）。请在推特上关注他们，账号为下划线 Alex Rowland。
And thanks also to menswear designer Bryce Paterson of the Black Tux. Voice talents this episode were Pat Masidi Miller, the great male renunciation, Matilde Bio, and Beau Brummel was played by Felix Trunch. People can find his work in the fiction podcast, wouldn't overcoats and quid pro Euro. And Roman Mars is the dandy cult leader of this whole series. There's a portrait of painting the things we love. Before the great male renunciation, so many things that we now think of as feminine were once masculine, like high heels were first worn by men because the heels were useful for
还要感谢男装设计师布莱斯·帕特森（Bryce Paterson）来自The Black Tux。本集的配音演员有帕特·马西迪·米勒（Pat Masidi Miller）、伟大的男性放弃者玛蒂尔德·比奥（Matilde Bio），而博·布鲁梅尔则由费利克斯·特伦奇（Felix Trunch）扮演。人们可以在虚构播客《Wouldn't Overcoats》和《Quid Pro Euro》中找到他的作品。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列的邪教式领袖。在我们热爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。在伟大的男性放弃之前，许多我们现在认为是女性化的东西曾经都是阳刚的，比如高跟鞋最初是由男性穿的，因为鞋跟有助于
writing stirrups. Same thing with diamonds. Like many kind of feminine fliers, diamonds were actually worn by men before they were worn by women. An author, Rachelle Bergstein, says that about 40 years ago, the diamond industry tried to get men back into it. They created a series of very hokey ads in the 80s, which are so on the nose, they hired sport stars
踩马镫。钻石也是如此。就像许多女性化的饰物一样，钻石在被女性佩戴之前实际上是由男性佩戴的。作家罗谢尔·伯格斯坦（Rachelle Bergstein）说，大约40年前，钻石行业曾试图让男性重新戴上钻石。他们在80年代创作了一系列非常老土的广告，这些广告直白得离谱，他们甚至请来体育明星
to say things like, my diamond makes me feel masculine. I'm just just protesting a little too much. But then, outside of the industry's purview, something happened, which they really didn't anticipate, which was that rappers started wearing diamonds as the symbol of their success. Prominent men of color of their own accord injected new life into the diamond industry.
说一些诸如“我的钻石让我感到充满阳刚之气”之类的话。这简直是此地无银三百两。但随后，在行业视野之外，发生了一件他们完全没有预料到的事情，那就是说唱歌手开始将钻石作为他们成功的象征。有色人种的杰出男性自发地为钻石行业注入了新的活力。
On a fundamental level, it showed guys that wearing gemstones could be cool, that it actually is something aspirational and something that shows off status, which is of course what we're all told we're trying to do with our gemstones. But you know, not all gemstones necessarily. I'm gonna sound so white when I say this,
从根本上说，它向男士们展示了佩戴宝石可以很酷，这实际上是一件令人向往的事情，也是一种炫耀地位的方式，这当然就是我们所有人被告知我们试图用宝石做的事情。但你知道，不一定所有的宝石都行。当我说这话时，我听起来可能太白人了，
but bling meant a specific thing. It didn't mean sapphires or emeralds or opals. Your next articles of interest are diamonds. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但Bling（耀眼饰品）有着特定的含义。它并不意味着蓝宝石、祖母绿或蛋白石。你的下一期《感兴趣的物品》是关于钻石的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。